so you have a little boy kitto I do how
old is he eight months and two days I've
got to get this right and the little
darling woke me at 4 21 am this morning
uh with a particularly Troublesome
snuffle and cough but we are fine what
sort of personality do you think he's
got uh bubbly bouncy cheeky uh and
always smiling which is very sweet he's
just very optimistic he has a positivity
about life that is uh he wakes up
smiling and he basically lives his life
smiling which is wonderful to see his
glasses brimming over let alone half
full could say they will always be your
third child yes
um the first child that you brought home
from hospital yeah first take him child
um what what happened so flora and I did
IVF and struggle for a very many uh
years to conceive and eventually had
twins who we managed to get just beyond
20 weeks and then sadly in kovid they
came too early basically and
uh one came and went very quickly and
the second child
uh lived for a very long and difficult
day but we were able to share that day
with them and uh we then
uh came to terms with the loss
but you you never regret the journey
you've been on if you know what I mean
and you never regret trying albeit like
many parents we weren't able to take our
children home what happened when you
first found out that your wife was
pregnant
um well obviously most of all if you've
been on an IVF Journey it's relief trust
me it's such a tough Journey
particularly obviously for the woman
but as a couple IVF is a miracle you
know none of our none of these people
who have had IVF would have been able to
conceive 30 years ago as the pregnancy
progressed and the baby's got bigger
well first of all you realize you're
pregnant then you realize you've got
twins
uh and then obviously you get to a a
state of uh fundamental happiness and
excitement and all the usual things that
parents get excited about and Mild
Terror as well yeah
and then
when did you find out that things were
so we had a scan and scam was going fine
and then a couple of days later
um Flo didn't feel well and had some
symptoms so we went into hospital she
went into Hospital of course because I
couldn't go
and uh as a consequence I was then rung
and told well actually
um things are not going at all well and
she'd begun giving birth way too early
and how old were they at that point
uh 21 going to 22 weeks so it was early
yes
um uh but this process that went on for
a little while and we lost one child and
then we kind of I mean we spent nearly a
week in hospital so yeah
um and you're trying to literally hang
on to the second child and lots of mums
lose one part of twins and
um sadly that wasn't to be how was that
day you said it was a long time uh it
was a very long day and
you're so tired and you're so
overwrought and rung through and uh
and you are this also it's very tough
even in modern maternity units so all
around you mums and dads are giving
birth yes and you're tucked away in a
corner of a of a hospital
um trying to save a child or in reality
knowing because you've been given pretty
good advice
that is very very unlikely that your
child will either survive or that will
survive in a healthy form as well and
that if you're you can take said child
home there is a high degree of risk of
significant uh deformity or disability
by reason of coming so early you know
they just don't develop in the right way
they need to be in mum's tongue
basically
so uh
that's a tough gig because all around
you you can hear women giving birth
uh people being all excited
uh and
which makes it very difficult for the
parents and we've been through it but as
I say hundreds and hundreds and hundreds
of other people have been through it as
well and you spent a lot of time talking
to your child as well
yes we had a very special
a couple of hours
where we communicated our hopes and
dreams and fears and aspirations
and sadnesses and also
um
uh and obviously held his hand and and
was with him and in circumstances where
we probably understood this may not
have a happy outcome
but
um the fair point to make is
I've yet to meet a parent who didn't
appreciate even if it is a short period
of time in neonatal intensive care
when the hospital tries to preserve the
life but also makes a delicate judgment
call
that
um some time for the parents as this
life
takes what is inevitably or in 99 times
out of 100 is an inevitable course is
utterly priceless
and there's a very difficult
conversation that the surgeon has to
have the consultant has to have with the
parents about what you want us to do and
do you want to try and resuscitate do
you want to try and and that's not an
easy one but I would my lesson would be
that day we spent uh albeit long and
difficult was priceless yeah a day that
you will always be yeah of course you
you you
um
you try your hardest to
encapsulate it remember it and savor it
because you realize it's probably not
going to be
um
uh long lasting and the bit that really
affects you is
um you know there are lots of mums and
dads who don't get another chance so you
know in the back of your mind this may
be your only time ever in a Maternity
Ward and you may only have a day and
that if that's what life brings you
that's what life brings you but
that's a lot to take in
what did you call your your babies uh
Teddy and Rafe obviously this is such a
such a the worst thing that any parent
can go through the absolute worst thing
that any parent can go to through but I
guess having people like yourselves in
Parliament who go through these things
means that you can Advocate on behalf of
other people who've experienced it as
well which you have done so I had a
49-day sabbatical courtesy of this Truss
where I was on the back benches which
meant I could take part in uh
the back bench debate on this particular
issue and I was able to speak on this
and make the case on this and have
continued to advocate in a variety of
forms with Department of Health with
individual ministers Maria Caulfield has
been very helpful and also to try and
um
uh advocating you know the letters MP
give you clout there's no doubt
whatsoever and whether it's myself or my
labor colleague Terry Perkins or others
who've been through this and there is an
all-party group on baby loss of which
cabinet members set it up and many
people one of the health ministers will
Quince is very active in that as well
there is a very strong Voice cross party
in Parliament
making the case for uh better outcomes
better services
and shouting the corner for those who
feel
uh utterly devoid of a voice the neonato
care bill is currently going through
Parliament something that you have
pushed for and supported and that's
about giving people proper time off to
after something like this yes
um I I think it's long overdue it has
got cross-party support
um it's in its last stages in Parliament
right now and bluntly it provides
support to an individual who's been
through this
um because you can't go back to work
straight away and you shouldn't be
fundamentally penalized in your employee
status by reason of a disastrous
maternal event that has affected you you
um are also pushing for lesser postcode
lottery in terms of care it is an honest
fact to say that in this wonderful
country it is not a universal nature of
care and you could be trying to give
birth or having a difficult pregnancy in
a particular part of the country and you
will not get as good a service
as you possibly will do in a specialist
Hospital in the center of London where
there are an awful lot of very
impressive professors and experienced
people do you think it's good enough for
maternity care at the minute I think
listen I think it is very good I know
that there's things like the oxygen
report and other reports bluntly we it
is very good in this country but it
could be a lot better you know um it's
2023 we could a we should have as close
to Universal approach secondly there
could be better guidance of how you deal
with uh births at 21 22 23 24 25 weeks
and a better understanding of how you
handle that
and every child is different every
number is different but we could be a
lot better at that and I think they are
heading on that Journey
I can imagine that the
when you were pregnant with um when your
wife was pregnant with kiddo it must
have been a stressful Journey for the
obvious reasons but when he arrived
healthy
that must have just been I can't almost
imagine what
um relief happiness and and the honest
truth is
um the degree of pain for those who
sadly are not able to conceive and take
I'm a child is enormous and they will
never get over that they just they you
just don't get over that
um your life goes on you get up you try
to go to work you try to have a positive
outlook on life
but uh you know there are too many
people out there who really struggle
with that so
uh it's mostly relief
and then obviously the underlying
happiness of and the Delight of 421a
wakeups and I was saying obviously about
him being such a glass half full child
yes he's a very very lovable young man
who it seems
worryingly optimistic about everything
in this rather tricky complex World
which is delightful and that's the most
the sweetest part of his character is
that
basically he seems just very chirpy
about everything
my pleasure